Hi, uh. Welcome to Solicitor RKLS Channel.
Um. Good evening or good morning wherever you are.
Uh. My name is Ronald Yanguin.
I'm a Solicitor,
Supreme Corps of New Zealand Wales.
Uh. Today I want to talk to you about um.
A topic subject that uh.
Seems to be affecting a lot of the immigrants.
As you know I period
period like to do bring on topic
or subjects that are affecting different people.
Uh. This week I've dealt with this in everywhere. Uh.
There. There is uh.
One. One of my clients uh.
Was travelling from abroad
and obviously um.
I had a similar one last week and the week before.
Now it's important that uh.
I bring this to your attention
because there seems to be a lot of this happening
and people may be caught out.
It's about um.
A sponsor uh.
Losing their sponsorship licence
and consequently how this impacts or affects uh.
Those who have got.
Who are here on the base of the C O S.
Um. Quite importantly, um. Uh.
An employee can't have their licence suspended,
they can have their licence revoked,
they can have their licence not renewed.
However, all these conscorts
ultimately a result in affecting the status of those
under which they were sponsored for
by that particular employer.
Typically employers have got uh. Uh.
Honor responsibilities and 2
home affairs to keep records to.
Can comply with various compliance issues
which sometimes they do,
sometimes they don't.
And if They don't.
Then they come to time when
they need to renew their license
and this may not be done
for failure to adhere to those particular conditions
under which they were issued. Ultimately,
this will affect individuals who came to this country
on the basis of those sponsorships
that they work in different places.
Now, um, typically
it's important to note that
in the unlikely event that this happens,
then the first response will be issued with 60 days
normally to either find another sponsor
to switch employment
or tend to relieve the country.
Um, they will only be given those conditions to
find another employer
in so far as they have not been involved
in the activities that has LED to their sponsors
licence being revoked,
if that makes it
makes any sense.
Essentially
you should not have taken part in any way
in the activities that LED to your employer being
employer's licence being revoked
if that has happened
a bit as it may.
Um, if you are travelling abroad also be,
be careful and make sure that you check
with a registered sponsors
that your sponsors licence is valid, eh,
because if you travel out of the country
you may not be able to get back in
and if you do,
you may have to be detained first.
And if detained
that may call you some,
some problem and bother. Uh,
we have to do with some scenarios whereby uh,
some clients have been detained
and We having to deal with our office
to get them released.
However, most importantly,
I would like to bring to your attention that
if you find yourself in that situation, um,
please get in touch with that law. With that.
With the law
solicitor to advise you immediately.
Because you may need to consider
making another application,
uh, before, uh,
your time has lapsed
and the time is limited.
So the sooner you do it, the better.
Get in touch with the solicitor. Or, uh,
if you want any more details about this,
you can always get in touch with us
to guide you.
I hope this helps you,
those who may fall in that category.
If you're travelling abroad,
please do make sure that you check this.
And if you're not sure about the state of employer,
then do not travel over the country,
otherwise you may not be able to get in.
Thank you and goodbye.